[MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
>> There's a cancer in the education
system.
Student's with this cancer are two and
a half times more likely to fail a grade.
They're less able to focus,
less able to memorize, and
in a fundamental affront to
the purpose of education,
this cancer inhibits a student's
ability to create new brain cells.
It's not an uncommon cancer.
The majority of American students
experience it to some degree by the time
they're teenagers.
And yet, our education system doesn't set
aside the resources to deal with this.
Now before I name this cancer, I want to
tell you why I'm talking to you about it.
Before I came to the GSB, I lived and
worked in downtown Detroit, where I
helped start a coding boot camp company.
I'm proud to say that we trained
hundreds of adults in a new career path,
software development.
But what bothered me at the time was
that we were turning away hundreds more.
And as I looked at their applications,
I realized we weren't turning them away
because they had bad attitudes, and
it wasn't because they
lacked the right motivation.
Instead, they'd been so deeply underserved
by their K through 12 education,
they were incapable of
learning what we had to teach.
So I looked into the best analysis and
research to understand, what is so
wrong with K through 12?
And what I found was that
the culprit isn't teacher tenure.
And it isn't because there aren't
enough iPads in the classroom.
Instead it's this cancer.
It's called childhood trauma, and
there are many different types.
>From having a parent in prison, to
witnessing domestic violence in the home,
to experiencing emotional neglect,
to sexual abuse.
But the common thread,
the real definition of childhood trauma
is this, it's the experience for a child,
repeated over years of their
safest relationships undermined.
The people and environments that
should represent safety and security,
instead become dangerous and threatening.
Now, the impact of this trauma is real.
People who experience it are more
likely to have heart disease,
more likely to be depressed,
more likely to commit suicide.
But one of the most pervasive and
yet least discussed impacts of this,
is its impact on learning.
And to help us understand exactly
what that might look like,
let's think of a case study,
a student named Shawn.
Let's say Shawn's dad is in prison and
as a result his mom works long hours
to make up for that financial burden.
When she comes home from work,
she's exhausted and
emotionally unavailable for Shawn.
Let's say Shawn wakes up some
mornings to an empty house.
His mom is already gone to work and
he's left wondering if anyone
is looking out for him.
Now as Shawn experiences these things,
his body responds in the same way that all
of our body respond to stressful events.
His breath gets short,
his heart beats faster, and his brain,
as it floods with adrenaline and cortisol
experiences a fight or flight response.
It's concerned with only one thing,
getting Shawn out of the situation.
It can't think any deeper than that, and
that's where Shawn's
learning gets affected.
Because every morning when Shawn goes
to school, it looks like he's leaving
the cause of his trauma at home,
but the effects stay with him.
He may look like he's
ready to learn algebra or
grapple with the big questions of history,
but his mind has become accustomed to
responding to trauma and
that doesn't stop in the classroom.
His brain is physiologically
incapable of learning and
his brain chemistry becomes
the barrier to a quality education.
Now, a fight response in the classroom
might look like Shawn acts out and
is disruptive.
A flight response might look like
he's uninterested or disengaged.
And if Shawn is at a school that
hasn't trained its teachers
to recognize these things as potential
symptoms of childhood trauma,
Shawn just might be ignored
as a problem child.
And if he never gets to a school that
is prepared to understand what he's
struggling with, he might get robbed
of an education that he deserves.
His very future becomes
a victim of his trauma.
Now, I know we're talking about
the education system here,
child protective services is supposed
to stop this trauma from happening.
But what I think is so
critical to understand and
the reason why I'm standing here talking
to you today is that I think the schools
have a critical role to play in
helping students get the tools and
resources they need to overcome the impact
of the trauma they've already experienced.
I think we need to redefine what
we consider a quality education.
It's not enough to think of school
as simply transmitting information.
I think schools need to prepare the minds
of the students to absorb that knowledge
because it doesn't matter how fantastic
your curriculum is, if you're
trying to teach students whose brains
are insulated by the effects of trauma.
We should all care about this because
we're all stakeholders in the education
system, or taxpayers who fund it,
or current or
future employers who will hire
the people who graduate from it.
And many of us are current or
future parents.
We're going to send our kids into it.
Now, if we as the stakeholders
exist in a society that
is full of people who were robbed of their
education, we shouldn't be okay with that.
Now I realize that there's been
a lot of doom and gloom so far, and
I'm not a doom and gloom kind of guy.
I have a lot of great things to share
about three schools across this country
that are doing meaningful things
to address the impact of trauma.
The first one is a high
school in Washington state.
They've taken an institutional approach.
They've put aside the resources to
train teachers to recognize and
deal with the impact of trauma
among their students, and
hired mental health
professionals on sight.
What this looks like is when a student
like Shawn is acting out in class,
his teacher doesn't ask herself
initially what's wrong with Shawn, but
what happened to him?
And with that is the beginning
of the conversation.
Shawn can start a journey of recovery,
starting in the classroom and
culminating in the office of that
mental health professional on campus,
helping him get through
what he's experienced.
Another great example is
the elementary school in Texas called
the Momentus Institu.
They've addressed one particular
symptom of childhood trauma,
which is the inability to
regulate your emotions.
The way they've done that is they've
turned to a trusty glitter ball.
They've given every single student
a plastic ball filled with water and
glitter, and it holds the key to teaching
students like Shawn how to overcome
his lack of emotion like elation,
because when he gets upset or angry, he's
trained to first shake up that glitter
ball and not respond to his emotion.
As the glitter swirls around inside the
ball, Shawn thinks about what he's feeling
and what the most productive
way to respond to that is.
Once that glitter has settled, so has he.
And over the course of years,
he learns how to overcome
the emotions he's experiencing,
and every day
that might have been lost to emotions that
are out of control are reclaimed by Shawn.
The final example is being developed
right here at Stanford GSB.
It's called Mindful Kate's Wealth,
and it's an app that allows a high
school teacher to start a day
with a mindfulness exercise.
Now in addition to all of
the wonderful benefits of mindfulness,
this activity, it's on on the phones of
students, culminates in one question.
What emotion do you
feel most this morning?
The result is a roster for the teacher.
Every student and every emotion.
So that when Shawn has his head on his
desk in the back of the classroom,
his teacher knows that he reported
feeling really sad this morning and
instead of telling him to shape up, she
can walk beside him, ask what happened and
reclaim one more day of Shawn's education.
Our education system may have a cancer,
but it's not a death sentence.
There are meaningful things that
schools across this country are doing
to help students like Shawn overcome
the impact of their trauma.
If we, as the stakeholders in the
education system, can help these schools
set aside the resources necessary to
value their students' mental health
as much as their test scores, then we
could see some dramatic improvement.
If all of us as the stakeholders can
redefine how we consider quality
education, then maybe we
can help give Shawn and
people like him all around this country,
their education back.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]